je sais que ça va vous faire réagir qui
est le mieux payé en 2018 et vous
n'allez pas être au bout de vos
surprises le youtuber le mieux payé au
monde
à 8 ans le petit ryan a gagné cette
année plus de 19 millions d'euros c'est
deux fois plus que l'an passé à ses
vidéos où il teste des jouets ont été
vus 26 milliards de fois alors l'es5
youtuber qui sont les mieux rémunérés la
source c'est le magazine forbes de très
sérieux magazine forbes enfin il ya donc
ryan toys review caisson que ce petit
garçon pour 19 millions d'euros puis un
youtube heures qui fait des blagues
jake paul pour 18 millions d'euros duo
de perfect lui ce sont des vidéos
décalées
dan tdm qui êtes un gamer vous savez
c'est son ca me fait c'est les regardent
ils adorent ça et jeffrey star qui fait
du las du make-up pour 15,8 millions
d'euros qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette histoire de ce petit garçon d'à
peine 8 ans moi ce qui me remettent dans
cette histoire c'est la répartition des
revenus si vous voulez parce que je sais
que ses parents chillon et lohan qui
s'appelle car ils ne bloquent 15% des
revenus de l'enfant qui seront donc
accessibles à sa majorité
mais que devient le reste de cette
fortune et bien a priori c'est la marche
des parents et ça ça me gêne parce que
ça veut dire que les parents se font de
l'argent ça veut dire que vous voudriez
qu'on légifère comme on l'a fait pour
les enfants du spectacle et m'a dit
c'est ni plus ni moins que
l'exploitation d'un enfant moi je suis
désolé il n'a pas l'air très malheureux
non plus un oui mais ça n'empêche c'est
du travail comme un must pour lui semble
ça veut dire quoi aussi ça veut dire que
quand on lui offre un cadeau ils se
rendent plus compte parce qu'il passait
ses journées à tester des jouets et je
suis désolé mais j'ai toujours ce truc
de mire qui regardent ces vidéos alors
on sait qu'il ya des enfants qui vont
les regarder
les enfants adorent ils peuvent oui mais
il peut y avoir des gens un peu dérangé
qui vont mater ce genre de jeux vidéo et
moi c'est vrai que ça me dérange avoir
un gamin de 8 ans ou ses vidéos sont
accessibles à tout le monde y compris
aux plus pervers ah oui mais même si
celle-ci bomba ne prête pas à la
perverse souvent temps je vous dit que
moi j'ai une vie de merde mais les gens
qui regardent ces vidéos parce qu'à
pâques des gosses d'accord parce que moi
je trouve que c'est d'une tristesse sans
nom du déballage des cadeaux comme ça ça
permet aussi de savoir ce que vaut le
cadeau si l'enfant va l'apprécier
il ya dans la boîte est ce que je
voulais vendus sur la fiche de la boîte
et correspond à la réalité du présent à
l'intérieur aussi des adultes ces vidéos
dans ces cas là il vaut mieux
dans un magouilleur des meilleurs
joueurs le choeur des vierges je vous
entends vous êtes le choeur des vierges
oui les mecs ils l'enfant alors toi tu
dis il gagne que 2 millions d'euros le
pauvre qui dans le public on refuserait
aujourd'hui d'ouvrir des cadeaux et
d'encaisser 10 millions de repas mais je
ne soyez pas hypocrite je sors tu te
trompes francesca parce que j'étais un
peu de ton avis avant cette émission et
j'ai regardé pendant une grosse partie
de l'après-midi les vidéos puisque j'ai
encadré xavier travail j'essaie
d'apporter ce que je n'essaie pas donc
oui de savoir si la prendre à noël et en
fait je trouve assez jouissif le fait de
voir un enfant qui déballe un lézard en
peluche parce qu'on al'impression
finalement que c'est nous qui l' des
ballons aussi donc il ya aussi ce côté
un petit peu j'étais miroir balaïa
l'effet miroir donc j'avoue que j'étais
assez ému quand j'ai vu ce sont les arts
on peut lutter contre la française en
place mme de damien alors débutant qui
devient millionnaire grâce à youtube ça
vous choque que ça ne vous choque pas du
tout ça vous choque à 65% mais ça ne
vous choque pas à 35%